this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new iphone 12 and today i'm going
to be comparing it against the iphone 11
and i'm not only going to cover the
typical things such as the design and
performance
but also things like the display quality
we're gonna cover things like 5g speed
compared to
4g and also speakers and much more
let's go ahead and get this thing open
and i have to say that i'm excited for
this blue color
now to be honest i am not a fan of blue
i
love red but the red just doesn't look
good this year
but this blue looks fantastic
i love how deep and rich it is and i
love that the sides here
are darker uh i guess maybe i'm a fan of
blue now
now in the box we do not have ear pods
or a charging
adapter last year we had one but it was
a 5 watt super slow one so you probably
wanted to upgrade anyway
this year apple makes you buy it but we
actually have a better alternative this
anchor one costs less than apples
and it is about half the size so i'll go
ahead and link it down in the video
description below and on that topic
let's touch on
magsafe we have magnets built into the
new iphone 12
and you have different accessories such
as cases there's gonna be different
mounts
and a big one is this new magsafe
charger that can
fast wirelessly charge up to 15 watts
compared to the iphone 11 and other
iphones that are older
that do maximum of 7.5 watts now we are
doing a dedicated
charging shootout between magsafe and
regular charging and other wireless
charging
so if you want to see how fast the new
mac safe charger is make sure you
subscribe so you guys don't miss out on
that video
getting back to the design i have to say
that this color looks
awesome and it's interesting how much
different the new phone feels in your
hand obviously we have these
squared off edges instead of it being
round
but it definitely feels smaller and
lighter
as well and i've been using the iphone
12 pro for the last about 24 hours i've
waited to unbox this one
it feels dramatically lighter than the
pro let's go ahead and stack these and
it's interesting how much smaller
the 12 is despite the screen being the
same you probably can't even see it
right now
keep in mind the displays are the same
6.1 inches but the 12 is shorter
and narrower because of that the 12 is
definitely more comfortable in the hand
it definitely feels smaller and lighter
to be honest i thought this new square
design isn't going to be as comfortable
in the hand compared to this
nice rounded frame of the 11 but it does
actually feel more comfortable in the
hand it's easier to hold
especially if you put your finger
underneath like i do when you're
touching stuff and typing
the power and volume buttons are
actually lower on the phone and not just
because the phone is shorter
but interestingly apple actually
designed them to be lower from the top
the camera bump is larger to accompany
that larger lens that lets in more light
and with that we actually have a larger
flash as well
and the microphone stayed the same
whereas on the pro models they actually
made the microphone
smaller and lastly this new iphone 12
is actually quite a bit thinner than the
iphone 11 even though it's hard to tell
in your hands
because of the squared off design and
even on camera it's hard to show that
off because of how the glass is actually
bent and goes up
let's take a look at the fronts and wow
that is a massive difference in
bezel size now the 12 actually has a
thinner bezel than even the 11 pro
whereas the 11 standard one had a thick
bezel you guys can see the difference
right there
the 12 seems much more modern because
this play is completely flat instead of
being curved
and it meets up really nicely with the
frame and that should actually give you
a little bit more
durability and with that the 12 actually
has new ceramic
shield glass which apple says is four
times stronger
now before we go in depth in comparing
these displays and there is
a ton of differences let me give a shout
out to the sponsor of this video
squarespace if you've been thinking
about making your own website
squarespace is seriously the best way to
go
we've built multiple websites and you
can too with literally no web making
experience
you just choose a template customize
blocks of text and images
and easily move them around it's
incredibly simple affordable and ours
have been
running flawlessly for years now
bringing in new clients thanks to its
built-in seo tools so whether you're
making a website for a small business or
for literally anything else
go to squarespace.com max tech for a
free no
credit card required trial and when
you're ready to launch save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain comparing the displays
i can instantly see a difference the
upgrade is
massive apple got a lot of flack when
they release the iphone 10r
and the 11 has the same exact display
because
it was just slightly higher than 720p
and it was a lcd
screen where most of the competition are
making oleds or at least 1080p
screens well finally apple has updated
that and the 12 display
looks gorgeous we have a difference of
about
double the pixels we have almost 1.5
million pixels slightly less
compared to 3 million pixels so yes i
could tell that this display is
sharper another difference is how much
warmer the new 12 is
both do have true tone turned on and the
11
seems kind of like it's bluish compared
to this warmer color
i'm also noticing a difference in
viewing angle the iphone 11 as soon as i
twist it it gets much darker
it also gets more blue and i see a good
amount of reflections
whereas this newer one has less
reflections and the brightness and
colors
stay very similar comparing the maximum
brightness let me
max this out here and they look very
similar
as they should because apple's saying
they're both at about 625 nits typical
but because the iphone 12 has an
oled screen it actually has a peak
brightness of 1200 nits
meaning that outside it could actually
get brighter to help
combat the sun that will also help when
you're watching videos especially for
hdr
and here comparing both of these i
exposed for the displays and maxed them
out
the 12 definitely looks more vibrant and
the colors look richer and better
and the blacks are deeper as well
because it's an oled panel now
interestingly right now youtube is not
giving me an
hdr option on the 12 they might need to
update their app for that
but i am getting the option for 4k 60
instead of just
1080p so clearly the display on the 12
is much better in every single way now
what about the speakers well
we're gonna compare those go ahead and
put on your best pair of headphones
and let's take a listen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below now to me
i can tell a difference the 12 is better
in pretty much every way
now apple didn't say it was better but i
definitely can hear
that the highs are a little bit more
crisp the mids are a little bit more
full and we are getting a little bit
more bass as well
let's get into performance and let's
start by talking about 5g
apple is making a massive push here and
in my last comparison i tested the 12
pro against the 11 pro
and both of these actually have the same
exact modems and i saw a massive
difference
not only between 5g against 4g but
the 4g that comes with the iphone 12 is
so much faster than the 4g lte on the
11.
that's because these new iphones are
using qualcomm
modems the very best on the market
compared to the older iphones which use
intel that are much much slower i'm glad
that apple
isn't cheaping out on their lower priced
model like a lot of android companies do
they're putting the very best chips
including the a14
in this iphone 12 and we're actually
doing a comparison of 5g
versus 4g all across my city at
different times so if you guys want to
see a detailed test with reception and
speeds and streaming
make sure you guys click that subscribe
button now let's compare the cpu and
graphics performance i'm going to go
ahead and start geekbench
5 and the iphone 11 is no slouch it has
an a13 in it that is faster than even
the very best android phones
but with this new iphone 12 we have the
a14
processor that is the first five
nanometer chip on the market
which means that not only is it more
powerful but it's more power
efficient as well which is good when it
comes time to talk about battery life
here in just a sec
all right we have our results and i was
honestly expecting a little bit more
from the iphone 12
now we're still getting about a 20
improvement in single core
and a little bit more than that uh in
multi-core so it's still a great update
but comparing it to the iphone 12 pro i
actually got
4 200 with that one now that might be
because the 12 pro has 6 gigs of ram
both the 11 and 12 have four gigs of ram
but we'll see if this actually matters
in the real world i will be doing a
comparison between the 12 and 12 pro
after about a week of real world use so
subscribe if you guys want to check out
that video now let's go ahead and test
out the graphics performance and the
results are in
and man this is actually where their
improvement is
we have 6400 compared to 9258
so that's about a 50 improvement in
graphics and most new
apps are using metal now for
acceleration of course for
gaming that's going to be a big
difference so that is good to see
a such a nice upgrade and with that
let's talk about battery life now
obviously i have not had time to test it
i just unbox this in front of you but mr
who's the boss did an excellent shootout
between a bunch of iphones
and the results are really good news
now not only did we get more power and a
much nicer
sharper brighter display but the iphone
12
actually outlasted the 11 by over an
hour and a half and if you have an
iphone 10r
it actually outlasted it by two hours
and 10 minutes and that is
awesome so that is a really really good
improvement now
weirdly enough if you have an iphone 11
pro the 5.8 inch model the battery life
actually got worse
but for everybody else from the 11 10r
or the older iphones the battery life is
gonna be a nice improvement
and now let's talk about the cameras and
they really haven't changed that much
the ultrawide camera is the same the
front-facing camera is the same
and the main shooter actually has the
same sensor or as far as we know
but it lets in a little bit more light
with the f 1.6
aperture compared to f 1.8 now most of
the updates are
actually coming from the software we
have smart hdr3
and we have night mode on all cameras so
here you guys can see the some
comparison shots
compared to the iphone 11 or the 11 pro
so there are some nice upgrades
and not only do we have these massive
improvements in poor lighting
but in decent lighting diffusion is
actually better now as well
which gives us more detail we'll be
doing a detailed camera comparison next
week not only between the 12 and 11
we're also going to toss in the iphone
10r so that's going to be a great
video and finally let's finish off with
the prices and my final
verdict now the iphone 11 unlike the 11
pro
is still being sold when it came out it
was seven hundred dollars but now you
can pick one up for
5.99 so 600 bucks
in the iphone 12 instead of keeping that
same 6.99 it actually costs 7.99 so 800
bucks and if you want to buy the
unlocked version you have to pay 30
dollars more
so that is really unfortunate and now
we're looking at a price difference of
200
which is a good amount now of course the
12 does have a much
much nicer display we have the newer
processors we have better
cameras and along with that you have mac
safe
and the new 5g modems and much better 4g
lte as well so there's a lot of
improvements
but there is that 200 price gap now
personally for me
i would still go for the iphone 12
because
you are future proofing yourself we have
the new design we have that 5g built in
so if you're gonna keep your phone for
two
three maybe even four or five years like
some people do
i think it's worth getting it for that
5g chip and the new designs now
if you know you're going to keep it for
a year or two you're short on cash
600 is still a really good deal for your
phone it's still going to do an awesome
job even though it's not as new and
modern but go ahead and let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below
thank you guys for watching you guys can
click that circle above we have a lot of
new videos coming out
on both of these phones we have real
world comparisons photo comparisons
all sorts of great videos and if you
want to watch a great video right now we
have a couple
right over there thank you guys for
watching this has been max and i'll see
you in the next video